[Musique]
bonjour à tous alors juste petite info
mon anniversaire c'est dimanche
donc faut revenir dimanche on me
souhaiter et 46 ans alors moi j'aimerais
vous raconter l'histoire d'un tremplin
de plusieurs d'ailleurs et à travers ce
tremplin vous expliquer un peu mon
parcours à la fois personnelles aussi
professionnel est aussi ce qui m'a
construit et ce qui m'a permis d'être en
face de vous en tout cas d'être légitime
d'être là ce soir pour vous faire part
de cette expérience et que j'aimerai que
à la fin de cette soirée vous vous dites
j'ai envie de faire comme ça m'ira j'ai
envie d'entreprendre parce que c'est ça
la vie parce que c'est ça la société
alors moi voilà je suis une jeune fille
qui est née dans le 9-3 alors je suis
contente parce que sylvie l'a crié haut
et fort que la courneuve
voilà c'est des villes où on le vivre
ensemble existe depuis des décennies
depuis des années sauf qu'on l'a mal
interprétés souvent parle de la seine
saint denis comme un département négatif
où il se passe plein de choses sauf qu'à
chaque fois on met la lumière sur le
petit truc
le petit truc qui va faire qu'on va
donner une image négative
moi j'ai grandi je suis issu d'une
famille de huit enfants puis la
troisième
parmi les 8 es là il a fallu exister
imaginez dans une famille maghrébine
j'ai 46 ans donc c'était dans les années
80 il fallait exister à travers une
éducation par facile pour les filles
parce que on a appris à nos parents que
les filles bah voilà c'était strictes
c'étaient les études et encore si on
avait des parents qui toléraient sinon
c'était beaucoup la maison donc moi il
fallait que j'existe fallait que je
développe mon caractère et ce qui m'a
sauvé c'est le sport le sport m'a permis
de découvrir notre famille une famille
qui m'a permis d'avoir un autre oxygène
de rencontrer du monde de voir qu'il
existe aussi autre chose que dans la
cité que dans la banlieue et ce sport
m'a permis d'acquérir des valeurs qui
m'ont permis on se rend pas compte quand
on pratique du sport cas je vous
encourage en faire et surtout emmener
vos enfants à pratiquer du sport parce
que on se rend compte
dans la suite et quand on grandit et
comprendre la maturité que ces valeurs
du sport et nous permettre
d'entreprendre des choses juste
extraordinaire et surtout d'être
toujours positive parce que c'est ça la
vie faut être positif même quand c'est
dur parce que tout n'est pas facile mais
le fait d'être optimiste change beaucoup
de choses et donc j'ai eu la chance
d'être accompagné par des profs qui ont
cru en moi parce que ils sont dit tiens
ça me rater bonne en athlétisme donc
devrait aller vers ça et m'ont
accompagné pour aller faire un sport
études et là je leur ai dit stop
le sport études mes parents interne à
oublier ça n'existe pas chez nous c'est
interdit pour les filles alors oui
c'était mon frère soucis mais pour les
nanas c'est pas possible ils m'ont dit
mais si on va y aller chez ben alors
allez-y
ils ont mis un tel enthousiasme ça ça a
été mon premier tremplin on tremplin qui
m'a permis de sortir de voir autre chose
et sont allés mes parents étaient
convaincus qu'ils sont dits bon c'est
quand même des adultes qui porte mon
enfant donc pourquoi pas donc j'y suis
allé et comme j'ai appris à vivre dans
une famille nombreuse
au bout de deux ans alors que j'étais
dans un endroit idyllique j'étais à
fontainebleau dans un sport études à
fontainebleau et en fait j'ai pas
supporté la séparation de ma famille
donc je pleurais tous les mercredis vous
rappeler les cabines téléphoniques parce
qu'à notre époque y avait pas le
portable
j'appelais je pleurais ces mamans j'en
peux plus je me dis mais je comprends
pas tu m'a fatigué pour y aller et
maintenant tu pleures pour revenir puis
des bombes à écoute voilà donc je suis
revenue à aubervilliers parce que moi je
suis né à aubervilliers
donc c'est la ville qui est à côté de la
courneuve et la fin j'ai repris mes
études latin bac
et puis comme en banlieue on nous
apprend pas voir ce qui se passe de
l'autre côté du périph
parce qu'il faut rester entre nous faire
de l'entre- soit parce que voyez on
parle des bobos mais c'est la même chose
en banlieue il faut rester entre soi
parce qu'on y est mieux et donc je fais
un bts compta pas ce qu'est un bts
compta dans mon lycée 1
voilà alors je suis vacciné par les
stages de comptabilité je me rend compte
rapidement
waouh c'est pas pour moi alors je suis
pas fâché je suis mariée avec un prof de
gestion voyez donc comme ça via j'ai mis
une égalité parfaite par rapport à ça et
puis rapidement je me suis dit bon ça
m'ira tu vas faire quoi que tu vas
devenir donc je me suis
à retourner vers ma passion qu'est le
sport et là je me suis dit je vais
devenir professeur de sport et là je
deviens professeur de sport et
j'enseigne à la courneuve voyez donc
s'il y en a des liens le savais pas et
on a trouvé ce soir grâce à vous en
l'occurrence et donc j'enseigne et comme
je suis scorpions je suis quelqu'un
quand j'ai fait le tour j'ai fait le
tour je fais pas semblant je ne sais pas
faire semblant en plus ça se voit sur ma
tronche donc comme ça voyez donc comme
ça on est vacciné et l'a donc j'arrête
et mon mari me dit mais tu arrêtes pour
faire quoi là on n'avait pas encore
d'enfant ça va et parce qu'on en a trois
et là il va faire quoi je vous dis mais
je sais pas mais je dis mais je vais
m'occuper je vais créer une association
parce que je suis pas au chômage
j'ai décidé d'arrêter donc c'est pas on
n'a pas viré j'ai décidé donc je vais
m'occuper je vais créer une association
et puis je vais voir que je vais devenir
est donc bien entendu en créant cette
association j'avais envie de donner du
sens parce que j'ai vécu aussi avec ces
jeunes qui sont désoeuvrés parce qu'ils
n'ont pas d'avenir parce qu'ils ne sont
pas optimistes et caetera et donc à
travers cette association qui s'appelle
sporta vie donc c'est un vrai jeu de
mots en se disant qu un moment donné on
doit tous être acteur on doit tous se
prendre en main et il faut commencer
très tôt il faut donner cette conviction
à ces jeunes très très tôt et donc on
prend des jeunes
donc je vais vous montrer ça marche pas
mince une partie commencée voilà merci
est donc l'objectif de ce portable très
rapidement c'est quoi l'idée c'est
l'éducation par le sport parce qu'on a
compris avec mon mari qui lui est
enseignant aussi que le sport ça fait
vibrer elles ont fait pas de pratique de
ce sport parce qu'il ya plein de clubs
qui existent donc a pas concurrence
par contre on leur permet par cette
passion du sport d'aller vivre les
grands événements sportifs mais a
traversé en transmet quoi d acte de
citoyenneté de la confiance mais aussi
de pouvoir monter des projets de leur
dire que c'est possible parce que
souvent ils ont une image négative de et
donc forcément renvoi quoi quand on a
une image négative de soi quelque chose
de négatif
donc nous on essaye de cacher tout ça et
de leur dire mais vous êtes intelligent
vous est brillant sauf qu'on a on sait
pas oui les bons boutons
donc on va appuyer avec vous sur le bon
bouton je vais vous donner une petite
année comme alors ça ces jeunes qu'on a
emmené au brésil
pas plus tard qu'il ya trois mois à rio
on emmenait cent quarante gamins vivre
les jeux olympiques avec tout un projet
culturel tout un projet humanitaire et
de leur dire vous voyez vous habiter en
banlieue mais on fait des choses
extraordinaires et une petite anecdote
un 2002 quand j'ai lancé le premier
voyage c'était à séoul pour la coupe du
monde
et là je dis à tout le monde moi j'aime
aller loin dans ce qu'on entreprend on
va leur faire apprendre le coréen ces
petits jeunes de samedi et lundi non
mais ça n'ira tu délires complètement
déjà le français c'est limite
l'anglais oubli mais alors là tu nous
parles de coréens mais je suis dit mais
vous n'avez pas compris
s'il ya un objectif au bout mais ils
vont se déchaîner
ils vont tout faire pour apprendre cette
langue on a mis et d'ailleurs quand je
suis allé voir l'ambassadeur de corée
pour qu'ils mettent à 10 points après
gratos un bien sûr je n'avais pas du
tout à ce moment là et il me regarda
voyez un peu lors j'ai rien contre les
asiatiques mais en montrant rien et en
même temps j'imaginais instant mais lui
doit me prendre pour une dingue mais il
voyait que j'étais tellement tellement
convaincu de ce que je racontais qui me
dit ok je te mets un prof pendant un an
eh ben je peux vous dire ben là il ya
une magie quand j'ai vu ces gamins des
4000 logements de la courneuve à prendre
le coréen
j'en ai pleuré j'en ai chialé parce que
voilà ça manque quelque chose de fort
alors bien entendu je vous raconte c'est
pour voyage séoul afrique du sud machin
mais faut de l'argent
j'ai compris qu'il faut de l'argent pour
les associations a d'ailleurs s'il ya
des partenaires qui veulent venir n'y a
pas de souci donc qu'est ce que je fais
à ce moment là j'étais visionnaire mais
je le savais pas
sachez le donc je dis à mon mari j'ai
trouvé le bon partenaire indiqué jeudi
était fort bah ouais il fonde le dieu
visuel ils ont les droits de tous les
événements sportifs donc forcément ils
vont faire en sorte de nous aider et là
donc je me mets à bien sûr aller
rencontrer le président de l'époque
était patrick le lay un breton vous
imaginez et là je me mets tous les jours
pendant six mois à 10 heures du mat
appeler le secrétariat du président pour
avoir un rendez à l'ours qui savaient
pas qu'ils ne savaient pas c'est que je
faisais de l'endurance
voilà le report voyez à quoi ça sert et
donc est donc là je il finit par me
recevoir parce qu'il se dit m fatigue
est mais puise donc je vais les recevoir
on va plier le dossier puis comme ça
elle arrêtera d'appeler donc je me
présente et là il m'a coup de pression
oui les grands patrons j'ai dix minutes
à vous consacrer et là je dis ça tombe
bien ce président je parle très très
vite
en cinq minutes j'ai plié le dossier
alors en cinq minutes j'avais pu y est
le dossier mais on est resté une heure
et demie à envoyer
c'est donc et donc tu deviens
partenaires donc ça se passe super bien
et tout et puis à 3 4 ans après notre
partenariat un jour il me fais appeler
une dit samira il faut absolument que je
te vois et là je me dis ça mon mari
c'est mort les subventions comme il
c'est un breton et de me le dire en face
donc voilà donc du coup on va se
présenter
donc j'y vais avec un argumentaire comme
ça pour expliquer qu' il n'a pas intérêt
on peut s'en tenait à la veille dès 2005
veut rappeler en 2005 ce qui s'est passé
en banlieue donc j'avais vraiment tous
les atouts hélas après c'était pas du
tout pour ça c'était pour me débaucher
le gars il voulait me débaucher
hélas hélas je suis dit mais pour faire
quoi indy pour être commercial samira el
ton énergie à écoutes relatent une que
tu m'as pris
et ben forcément les annonceurs et
pourrait passer là et là je dis mais non
ça va pas être possible
ça va pas être possible parce que parce
que voilà et une des réflexions etc
mais j'ai besoin de toi finalement je
viens et là je lui dis ok mais une
condition indie laquelle je lui dis j'ai
envie de créer une fondation il n'y a
pas de fondation à tf1 donc je veux être
celle qui propose la fondation au groupe
parce que j'ai eu le recul à l'extérieur
et je sait vers quoi tf1 doit s'engager
et me dit est la meilleure personne pour
pour justement nous proposer un projet
et là je lui donc je fais le commercial
que j'adore vous le dis tout de suite du
pif le gars parce que j'ai adoré ça et
de là et de la donc voyez les tremplins
se construisent au fur et à mesure et de
là je me mets à akré akré la fondation à
lui présenté et là je lui dis voilà
l'afrique de l'est il faut absolument
que tf1 s'engage et voilà sur quoi on
doit aller donc je lui présente quoi je
lui présente un beau projet ah voilà
donc c'est ma petite famille est en fait
je lui dis voilà tf1 on a une vraie
responsabilité sociétale on doit
s'engager
on doit être acteur parce qu'on renvoie
des images qui sont fortes et donc on
doit être responsable
donc je te propose que dans les
programmes de la fondation on puisse
permettre à ces jeunes de banlieues qui
sont brillants qui ont tous leur place
dans nos boîtes de lait forme et de les
accompagner de leur donner les codes
parce que c'est ça le problème c'est les
codes le réseau aussi et de les intégrer
alors on va leur donner de la formation
parce que bien entendu on les envoie
dans des écoles mais ils savent une fois
qu'ils sont diplômés qu'elles sont pas
reconnus par les états par les
entreprises
donc y'a que ceux qui savent et qui ont
les bons réseaux les bonnes connexions
et c est ben nous on va les mettre dans
les bonnes écoles et grâce à ça eh ben
on a des ligues à boire ou des
jean-marie bakayoko des sanad et johanna
des samir al ghadir dilemme qui sont
journalistes pour d'autres qui sont qui
travaille dans le marketing dans les rh
dans les juristes et du coup on permet
de les embaucher
pendant deux ans avec un coach ide avec
une formation à la clé avec des parrains
des tuteurs des collaborateurs du groupe
qui sont engagés
l'accompagnement des ces jeunes et ça
c'est ça que vous faire faire ça ils
peuvent attendre de personne
nous devons accompagner justement les
jeunes et leur donner des tremplins
on a tous des réseaux dans nos poches à
regarder vos poches là sont plaints de
réseau mais à quoi il sert crs dans les
poches à rien alors faites en profiter
votre voisin arrêter avec les liens du
sang le copain du copain du copain du
copain du machin mais offrait le à des
gens vous connaissez pas vous verrez
comment on dort bien punaise quand on
est quelqu'un qu'on connaît pas parce
qu'on l'a fait avec une grande sincérité
avec un engagement avec des avec des
convictions les parcs on a dans les
tripes et ça c'est important et ça c'est
important
et moi j'ai envie de vous donner alors
il ya plein d'autres projets mais je
vous invite à aller sur notre site
alors aujourd'hui moi j'ai envie de vos
traces mais de poids comme message c'est
tous autant qu'on est ici on peut
s'engager
tous autant connaît on est capable de
créer des tremplins pour le voisin la
voisine etc
mais pour ça pour avoir la conviction
tous ensemble on doit pouvoir et on doit
le faire on doit pouvoir inspirer semer
des richesses du savoir faire parce que
ensemble si on se réunit tous à un onni
à chacun son niveau parce que voilà il y
en a qui peuvent plus notre moi mais
c'est pas grave on juge pas ce qu'il
faut c'est être active ce qu'il faut
c'est s'engager
ce qu'il faut c'est justement permettre
la banale quand il ya quelqu'un qui a la
banane quand vous savez que vous avez un
petit peu contribué à asson à à son
épanouissement
mais qu'est-ce qu'on sent mieux dans sa
peau qu'est-ce qu'on se sent mieux quand
on réussit à apporter du bonheur pour
quelqu'un et ça c'est important
et moi aujourd'hui d'ailleurs si je suis
là c'est grâce à un homme voyez donc
pour parler de mixité d'ailleurs je vais
nommer s'appelle jean pierrot bergé qui
est directeur de la com de bouillie mots
qu'a donné mon nom à béatrice et qui est
venu discretos me voir en face à bira
voilà ce serait bien et c est pas merci
pierre merci parce que grâce à toi j'ai
pu partager cette belle expérience mais
aussi comme je suis une boulimique de
projets j'ai aussi créé une agence de
com d'ailleurs devant jova nicolas
bordas et je suis ravi qu'il soit là
parce que c'est grâce à des mesures
comme ça aussi
contribuons à créer une agence de com et
là je vous laisse le plaisir d'aller
voir parce que pareil
grâce à des réseaux d'entreprise des
gens parce qu'au début je vais vous dire
une petite anecdote quand nicolas il m'a
dit oui grâce à claude cohen qui est une
femme mais qui porte un nom masculin
dont vous voyez un peu le le charisme et
bien au début je me suis dit c'est caen
qui va me lâcher quoi nicolas c'est pas
possible qu'il n'ait fait avec
conviction et avec plein de et ben 10
ans après on va fêter nos 10 ans à la
fin du mois ça fait dix ans que nouvelle
cour existe ça fait dix ans que cette
agence de coûts de communication qui se
trouve à la courneuve existent et qui a
permis à des jeunes de s'épanouir dans
la communication
voilà merci
[Musique]